So let's do a quick add on to our story about
yesterday's debate. I wanted to separate the
analysis of the content from this story. This
is kind of its own thing. So CNN fabricated,
they, we knew they were going to set up this
confrontation between Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren about the 2018 meeting during which
Bernie Sanders is accused of saying a woman
can't win. Bernie denied it. CNN went on like
Bernie had admitted it and said to Warren,
how did you feel when Bernie told you that?
Even though Bernie denied it after the debate,
Bernie Sanders went over to Elizabeth Warren
extended his hand for a handshake and Elizabeth
Warren pulls her hand back, sort of surprising.
Bernie says something while kind of wringing
her hands. Uh, then Bernie kind of puts his
hand out in a Whoa, hold on a second way,
listens to the next thing Warren says, and
eventually does a kind of forget it hand signal
and turns around and walks away. And of course,
the question was, which Tom Stier was in a
position to hear what was said during that
moment. Bernie walking up with the intention
of a shaking hands with Elizabeth Warren,
Elizabeth Warren, saying something that stops
Bernie short and ultimately gets some to say,
forget this, turns around and walks away.
Tom Stier was asked later what was said. He
coyly said, I didn't hear the conversation.
I think that's him saying, I'm not getting
into this. He was standing right there. Obviously
he heard it. He was looking right at them
and he was inches away. But he is probably
smartly staying the hell out of the way of
this.
So this actually is getting ugly now. Now
we, we have to admit that there is ugly on
both sides here, but it is not equal ugly.
And I'm going to explain that one of the things
that was said for the last couple of days
was that after Bernie got ugly with Warren,
after Bernie sent supporters out to trash
Warren, that Warren confirmed alleged that
Bernie said a woman can't win. Back in that
meeting in 2018 initially when it was revealed
that there were anti Warren talking points
being used by Bernie staffers, the Bernie
campaign said these were rogue staffers. We
did not authorize these talking points that
has fallen apart and I would be doing something
dishonest if I didn't tell you this. The Bernie
Sanders camp has now confirmed that they were
indeed using an anti Warren script in multiple
early States. And it's important because this
is different than the initial story that was
told.
If it is, um, uh, untrue that Bernie said
a woman can't win, it's disgustingly immoral
to accuse him of that. But now that Bernie
has admitted that the Sanders campaign did
utilize this anti Warren script and at least
a couple of early voting States, there is
something else here that Warren can rightly
be critical of Bernie for doing. But here's
the thing. If you come to me and you say,
David, please adjudicate what's worse is using
an anti Warren script when campaigning worse
or is falsely claiming that Bernie said a
woman can't win worse. Well, if it's a lie,
claiming that Bernie said a woman can't win
is worse for sure. Because the reality is
that the anti Warren script that Bernie deployed
framing Elizabeth Warren as the candidate
for the educated elites. It's not morally
wrong to do that. This is politics. Now, the
issue is Bernie and Warren seem to have agreed
back in 2018 not to attack each other and
by deploying the anti war script, Bernie Sanders
broke his agreement with Elizabeth Warren.
That's between them though, right? That's
for them to figure out. This is politics.
Scripts that go after other candidates during
phone banking and door knocking are used all
the time. The issue for us to figure out,
because our priority is removing Donald Trump
is whether any of this helps us do that. When
Bernie Sanders uses a script that attacks
Elizabeth Warren and early States, does that
jeopardize the likelihood of removing Donald
Trump? If Bernie is not ultimately the nominee?
Maybe it does. When a story is put out by
CNN with or without confirmation by Elizabeth
Warren, we don't know a w coordination with
Elizabeth Warren rather, she confirmed it,
but was there a coordination there? We don't
know if neither burning or Warren or the nominees.
What does this dust-up do for our chance to
defeat Donald Trump? That's why I've said
from the beginning, I do not want this to
get ugly in a way that helps Donald Trump.
It's starting to get ugly in a way that may
help Donald Trump. Now, I'll be honest, I
think all of this scandal this week does nothing
to propel Bernie nor Elizabeth Warren into
first place and buy, so buying time for Joe
Biden to remain in first place. It positions
Biden to start winning primaries, which may
have been the goal of all of this thing from
the beginning. Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter. Follow me there and send me
a message letting me know what you think is
the ultimate goal of all of this and who is
the real catalyst for this? Is this an establishment
plan? Is this a Warren establishment plan?
Is it a Warren Biden plan?
Is it truly just innocent stories coming blight?
Increasingly that's hard to believe. Let me
know what you think. I'm on Twitter at the
pack